this video was made possible by
curiositystream
watch the extended cut of this video
listen to my podcast or watch our
upcoming original exclusively on nebula
which you can get access to
for 15 a year through the bundle deal at
curiositystream.com
wendover there was a time earlier in
when there was no news but covet news
there was this time when
every word of every story of every front
page of
every paper either directly or
indirectly dealt with the coronavirus
but now many months on that
is no longer the case the world has
awoken
in a way that there is more of relevance
however
in certain circles in those most
dramatically impacted
covid is still everything
that is certainly the case in aviation
almost nothing they do nowadays is not
dictated by the
ever-present backdrop of the century's
first pandemic
most of what anyone has been talking
about recently including us
has been on how this will fundamentally
change the industry
on how the airline of 2029 will look
markedly different than that of 2019.
today though in october 2020 we're
nearing the one year mark
since when sars kovi ii is believed to
have made the jump from animal to human
with this amount of time behind us the
airline industry
has already changed the airline of
october 2020
is already different than the airline of
october 2019.
so to see what's happened already we're
going to look at eight flights
that for reasons either big or small
would have been considered strange
unique or even unimaginable just a year
ago today
but now are nothing out of the ordinary
we'll start with the end for one
aircraft
at least for a while on september 25th
qantas vhoqi
an a380 flew from dresden germany to
victorville california
a route that is quite clearly unordinary
for an airline based in australia
but it's not the route that made this
notable
vhoqi had been flown to dresden in march
for cabin refurbishment
by september though it became clear that
not only was the refurbishment
unnecessary
but that the aircraft was too therefore
the decision was made to put this fleet
of aircraft into long-term storage and
this particular flight from dresden
would mark the last time a qantas a380
would be airborne
until at least 2023
this demonstrates that this is the
soonest qantas believes passenger demand
could return to 2019 levels
when the a380 served as its flagship
aircraft
however the fact specifically that the
airline would bother
storing the aircraft rather than
scrapping or selling it
also marks a hint of optimism long-term
aircraft storage
is not cheap it involves quite regular
maintenance and monitoring
and so this means that qantas does truly
believe that demand
will return to the levels of before an
opinion not held
by all qantas desperately needs every
dollar they can get right now
so they would only spend money on
keeping their a380s if they truly
believe that there was a significant
need for super large aircraft in the
medium-term future
therefore while it's plenty easy to find
negative signs for the future of
aviation
this flight does represent a belief that
the good times will return
for airlines this next flight meanwhile
didn't and in some ways couldn't exist a
year ago
on october 8th southwest flight 1920
flew from phoenix arizona to san jose
del cabo mexico
this certainly looks like a fairly
normal flight just another big city to
resort town route
but the backstory behind it explains its
peculiarity
mexico is one of the few major countries
that has not restricted entry to
americans
so when the u.s emerged from lockdown in
may and june
cabo was one of the first international
destinations added back to southwest's
network
this is without a doubt due to the fact
that it's both open to americans
and crucially a leisure destination
airline demand
is traditionally split into leisure and
business and these two segments have had
very different stories
of recovery leisure demand picked up
quickly
and sharply as soon as stay-at-home
orders lifted
while business demand has barely
increased at all
this is no surprise considering that
overwhelmingly
offices are still closed conferences are
still cancelled and clients are still
cautious
therefore airlines have had to respond
by removing capacity from where people
travel for work
and adding it to where people travel for
vacation such as cabo
right now there's a huge amount of
capacity being dumped
into the florida and mexico markets for
example
in the coming winter there are 24
flights a week scheduled between new
york and cabo
versus just two a week last winter some
leisure destinations have not only
recovered faster but have come out
ahead versus how they were before this
is certainly the case with cabo
and the october 8th flight from phoenix
represented the first of many
with southwest adding the city pair to
their network
overall leisure is winning business is
losing
and therefore airlines that have
historically been more leisure oriented
like southwest have fared far better
than their more business oriented
competitors
one of those more business oriented
competitors is united which announced
this new route from milwaukee wisconsin
to fort myers florida
much like southwest's flight this
probably doesn't seem that strange
but for united it's a dramatic deviation
from the mean you see like most legacy
carriers
united has traditionally been a strict
follower of the hub and spoke school
of network planning every single flight
they fly
with a very limited exception either
originates or terminates
in dc newark chicago houston denver los
angeles san francisco or guam
their hub airports this flight though
along with a whole package of others
announced at the same time
does not united wouldn't break from
precedent without a good reason
and so this must mean something most
likely
it indicates a mix of desperation and
innovation
desperation because they're now
seriously competing on leisure routes
something they avoided before and
innovation because united
is reinventing its network design and
getting a little more creative
creativity and innovation is what pushes
an industry forward
and so even if it comes in the form of a
route that is just ever so slightly
different
it demonstrates a characteristic that
would be welcome
once the downturn is over airlines are
now willing to find revenue wherever it
might be
whereas in the past they might have only
chosen to pursue the most profitable
form of revenue
so this flight ua 2861 from guam to
singapore on a 787
is another that could never have existed
a year ago
now guam is a united hub but it's never
had flights to singapore
definitely never had these on a 787 and
absolutely never operated them without
passengers
and yet now four times a week they are
with the current lack in long-haul
flights which traditionally carry
freight in their belly holds
global cargo capacity is down meaning
prices are up meaning airplanes can
reliably turn
a slight profit flying passenger
airplanes without
passengers in a matter of months united
has turned its guam hub
essentially into a mini cargo hub with
regular flights stopping over from the
us
going on to asian destinations beyond
this
globally united now operates hundreds of
cargo only flights per week
even though one year ago it didn't
operate a single one
whether it'll turn guam into a major
passenger hub for the u.s to asia market
is an unanswerable question right now
but at the very least
this further demonstrates how airlines
will truly take any revenue they can get
even if it involves turning into a cargo
airline in a matter
of months revenue is of course half of
the equation for profitability
but the other part is of course costs
therefore for weathering this crisis
airlines need to get as much revenue as
possible
while also minimizing cost this american
airlines flight from
eagle county airport to aspen was not
about bringing in revenue
but rather about reducing costs you see
only 29 miles or 46 kilometers separate
these two airports
meaning nobody's really looking to fly
between them however
this flight was part of an overall
flight that went from dallas to eagle
county to aspen to montrose and back to
dallas
meaning a passenger going to montrose
would have to sit through at least
two stops now a passenger is much more
likely to take a one-stop
itinerary than a two so in a time when
american airlines is fighting for every
customer it can get
why would it fly such a clearly
uncompetitive itinerary
well the reason is that american didn't
really care how many people took this
flight
because it was always going to be very
close to none
they couldn't however just cancel it
because airlines in the u.s
received a package of financial aid from
the government in exchange for
among other things agreeing to continue
serving every airport they did
previously american had previously
served these three airports which
primarily act as
entry points for tourist towns each of
which implemented restrictions
preventing visitors during their stay at
home periods
this meant demand for traveling to these
places was essentially zero
in the case of aspen and may for example
just seven percent of american seats
were filled
therefore instead of operating three
different empty flights they rather
operated just one that stopped at
each of the three airports thereby
creating that 29-mile flight which was
at the time the shortest commercial
flight in america
until the cares act expired on october
1st american and other airlines found
ways to both stay loyal to their new
masters in the government
while also minimizing costs to the
lowest level
but back on the revenue side on
september 25th
qantas operated qf-1570 from canberra to
gold coast airport in
australia exactly one week earlier on
september 18th
queensland the state of the gold coast
is in announced that it was opening its
borders to the australian capital
territory the territory that canberra is
in
that very same day quantus announced
that it would start a new route between
these two airports
one week later now normally
when airlines announce new routes they
do so months
or even years in advance for example
when qantas announced a new route from
brisbane to chicago
originally slated to start in april 2020
but now pushed back
they did so in july 2019 a full eight
months in advance
to shorten this to one week is
unprecedented but with borders opening
and closing at a moment's notice
predicting demand has become incredibly
tough
so in this case qantas saw the demand
for travel to queensland was going to
surge
and they were able to respond lightning
fast allowing for them to capture it
other airlines around the world have
done the same and the industry
in general has become more agile and
data driven
these will be useful skills for airlines
to maintain long into the future
as when there is demand a company's
excuse
should never be that they couldn't act
fast enough to capture it
sometimes though it's strategic to
ignore demand
on october 6 american airlines flew its
last flight from greenville north
carolina
for at least a month but likely longer
an airline pulling service from a small
regional airport in a time of economic
crisis
is nothing unexpected but this case
stands out
the cut was originally announced as only
for a month from october 7th to november
4th
a date recognizable for its proximity to
the november 3rd u.s election
there's no reason for an airline to
believe that the economic conditions
that make a route unprofitable on
october 7th
would be resolved by november 4th if
anything they should get worse as winter
nears
so suspending a route for only one month
to save money
doesn't make sense in addition
this service suspension was announced
along with 14 others
impacting 14 small airports in 14
different states
including pennsylvania iowa north
carolina and other swing states in the
2020 election
also many of the states that american
airlines cut service to
have incumbent senators who polling data
indicate might lose on november 3rd
this includes tom tillis who as happens
when small airports lose their only
commercial service
immediately faced pressure from his
constituents to bring flights back to
greenville
american airlines is essentially playing
chicken with the us government
with cares act funding having now
expired airlines desperately want
more financial aid from congress and
with 15 routes to 15 states cut
there are now 30 senators that have to
answer for why they haven't passed an
airline relief bill
to help save these small towns service
in the end
three of these suspensions didn't go
through but most others were extended
another month
thereby ratcheting up the pressure on
congress by signaling that these
temporary suspensions
might not be so temporary if they don't
get the relief they say
they need well in the us and elsewhere
airlines continued survival is
increasingly linked to politics
in other places it's always been china's
aviation recovery has played
a key part in the country's narrative of
overall recovery
which is at least compared to other
places genuine
on august 28th chengdu airlines flight
2712 was the first to leave from the
airport that
eight months earlier undoubtedly played
a central role
in spreading the virus across the globe
wuhan chanhi international
this flight though was the first of
hundreds to leave wuhan that day
and that day in fact was the first when
the number of flights in the country
reached 100 relative to january 1st of
the same
year china's aviation recovery was fast
in part because china's virus recovery
was fast
the country's airlines are not
completely back to normal yet
their load factors and fares are lower
than before and their international
market is still nearly non-existent
but china's airlines along with those of
new zealand australia
and all the other countries that have
successfully curbed the virus
demonstrate that the economic crisis
cannot end
until the public health crisis does and
therefore no matter which one cares
about more
the route to recovery always starts
with health the youtube algorithm
as any creator knows is optimized for
one thing
keeping the average person on the
platform for the longest time
but for us in the educational niche our
audience likes different things than the
average youtube viewer
we know what our audience wants but
sometimes that doesn't line up with the
stuff that the youtube algorithm will
favor
for example i wanted to make this video
longer but i had to keep it within the
key 10 to 15 minute length
so that performance didn't tank instead
i've cut it down from covering 10
flights to just
8 and put an extended version with what
i thought were the least important of
the 10
on nebula this is just one of the many
pieces of exclusive content you can get
on there
including show makers the podcast from
real engineering and myself where we
interview other great creators such as
stephanie from real science or evan from
polymatter or our next nebula original
which we're putting the final touches on
currently and will release in a few
weeks of course the best way to get
access to nebula is through the
curiosity stream bundle deal
which also gives you access to all their
thousands of truly interesting
documentaries and non-fiction shows
which each entertain and educate
together
curiosity stream and nebula represent
the best deal in streaming because
at 15 a year it's the same price as a
month
at other single streaming services so
make sure to sign up
before the current sale pricing is over
at curiositystream.com
wendover